THERE IS STILL MORE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE THAT FACEBOOK AND OTHER
COMPANIES ARE HURTING AMERICA
AND DISTORTING OUR BRAINS.
A STUDY BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
HEALTH WHEN YOU FINDS THAT
FACEBOOK, JUST FACEBOOK HIM
AMONG MANY OTHER SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS CAN SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE DEPRESSION FOR PEOPLE
AND LONELINESS, AND THESE
FEELINGS GO AWAY WHEN A PERSON
GETS OFF OF FACEBOOK.
JUST A YEAR AGO, FACEBOOK
INVESTOR JOHN PARKER BRAGGED
THAT THEY MADE IT AS DESTRUCTIVE
AS POSSIBLE WITHOUT CARING ABOUT
THE HARM IT WOULD INFLICT.
TOM IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
"DISCONNECTED."
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
I'M NOT GOING TO ASK YOU IF YOU
ARE SURPRISED BY THIS BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU ARE NOT.
WHAT IS THE ANSWER FOR PARENTS
OF TEENS AND YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE WATCHING THEIR KIDS SLIP
AWAY AND BECOME REMOTE AND SAD
BECAUSE OF OVERUSE?
>> THE NUMBER ONE ADVICE I GIVE
ON THIS TOPIC IS WE TURN INTO A
KEEPING UP WITH THE JONESES
SOCIETY WHERE EVERYONE SEEMS TO
BE DOING WHAT EVERYONE ELSE IS
DOING.
SO THE AVERAGE AGE THAT KIDS ARE
GETTING THEIRS BURST SMARTPHONE
IS FIFTH-GRADE.
THAT HAS ALL THE SOCIAL MEDIA
AND IF WE ASK ANYBODY THAT'S
LISTENING, DO WE THINK THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA AS PARENTS?
THEY WILL SAY NO.
YET THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
DOING IT ANYWAY.
AND IT'S A CONFORMITY KIND OF
THING.
>> Tucker: IT IS CONFORMITY.
SOME MAY BE THE FIRST STEP IS
SAYING IT OUT LOUD WHICH
EVERYONE SUSPECTS, IT'S
DESTROYING OUR SOCIETY AND
MAKING US DUMB AND SAD.
>> I WAS HAPPY TO SEE A STUDY
COME OUT, BECAUSE THEY ARE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR A STUDY.
THE FACT THAT THE SUICIDE RATE
AMONG TEENAGERS HAS GONE UP 70%
SINCE 2006 AND ALL OF THE
RESEARCH BEHIND THAT, --
>> Tucker: PLEASE RESTATE
THAT, 70% AND THE RESEARCHERS
ARE SUGGESTING THAT THAT IS
BECAUSE OF SOCIAL MEDIA.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU ARE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA ALL THE TIME, WHAT
ARE YOU CRAVING?
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR FEEDBACK.
LOOKING TO FILL AN INTERNAL
SENSE OF SELF OF AN EXTERNAL
SOURCE.
AS SELF-ESTEEM, JOY AND
HAPPINESS IS AN INSIDE-OUT THIN
THING.
>> Tucker: SO THE CIGARETTE
COMPANIES NEVER KILLED THAT MAN
MANY, AND YET THEY GOT HAULED UP
AND BARBECUED AND BASICALLY
FEDERALLY REGULATED INTO NEAR
EXTINCTION BECAUSE OF THE THREAT
THEY OPPOSED TO KIDS.
BUT NOBODY DOES ANYTHING ABOUT
IT BECAUSE WHY?
>> THAT SHOWS RADIATION DANGER,
AND THEY HAD TO GO TO STATE
COURT IN ORDER TO GET THE
FINDINGS RELEASED AND WE KNOW
WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT'S BEHIND THAT,
AND LOBBYING, AND THEY ARE NOT
THINKING ABOUT THE BOTTOM LINE.
>> THE PEOPLE THAT ARE RAISING